[Musica]
sono innamorato della magia delle parole
e che è un amore che mi è stato
trasmesso dal mio papà accanito lettore
nonché grande appassionato di
enigmistica
qualche giorno fa ero a casa dei miei
genitori e lui era nell'altra stanza che
risolveva a voce alta un cruciverba
io l'ho sentito che diceva 27
orizzontale rimanere sbalordito e
sconcertato tra secolare 8 verticale di
chi si comporta in modo strambo bislacco
27 orizzontale pasto abbondante e
raffinato luculliano mentre lo ascoltavo
ho avuto l'ennesima conferma della
bellezza e della ricchezza della lingua
italiana la lingua italiana costa di
circa 270.000 unità lessicali dette le
semi parole insomma parole però sono
anche le varie forme che in esse mi
prendono una volta flessi per esempio il
6 mandare porta con sé le varie forme
del presente indicativo vado mai quelle
dell'imperfetto indicativo andavo andavi
e via coniugando la maggior parte dei
sostantivi a un singolare e un plurale
casa case vestito vestiti molti
aggettivi poi hanno addirittura quattro
uscite bello bella belli band in totale
ammonta a più di 2 milioni il numero
delle parole dicibili e scrivibili in
italiano 2 milioni per avere un'idea di
confronto prendiamo l'inglese la seconda
edizione riveduta e corretta dell'oxford
english dictionary costa di venti volumi
pubblicati nel 1989 più tre volumi
aggiuntivi usciti tra il 93
nel 97 complessivamente racchiude circa
615.000 parole nemmeno un terzo
dell'italiano in pratica possiamo dire
che in italiano
esiste una parola per tutto facciamo
qualche esempio simpatico esiste una
parola per descrivere una persona che si
vanta di capacità o impresa inventate sì
smargiasso esiste una parola per
descrivere una fanciulla prosperosa e un
po desueta ma è molto carina sgarzi jona
esiste una parola per descrivere una
persona che ha perso il marito vedova è
una persona che ha perso un genitore
orfano è una persona che ha perso il
figlio
no
2 milioni di parole 2 milioni di parole
ma non esiste nemmeno una che indichi la
perdita di un figlio
io credo sia giusto così
credo sia giusto così perché è talmente
inaccettabile che è impossibile
racchiudere in un solo termine quello
che è senza alcun dubbio il più grande
dolore per un essere umano perdere un
figlio è qualcosa che va contro la
logica contro la natura contro
l'evoluzione contro tutto anche contro
la lingua italiana
quando muore un genitore per quanto
doloroso possa essere è qualcosa che
siamo preparati ad affrontare o magari
non siamo preparati ma lo sapevamo
sapevamo che prima o poi sarebbe
successo sappiamo che prima o poi
accadrà
speriamo il più tardi possibile mark
adrano i nostri genitori rappresentano
il nostro passato ci dicono da dove
veniamo
esattamente come noi rappresentiamo il
loro futuro
siamo la traccia più evidente del fatto
che loro sono esistiti che sono stati
qui e quando vuole un figlio è proprio
l'idea di futuro che viene a mancare
come se qualcuno spegnere l'interruttore
del tuo futuro
cinque anni fa proprio in questi giorni
ero alla guida della mia auto accanto a
me c'era mia moglie e dietro c'era la
mia bambina
sarà che all epoca aveva poco più di un
anno era una splendida domenica
primaverile e come spesso facevamo e
facciamo tuttora stavamo andando a
pranzo nei miei suoceri era però una
domenica particolarmente felice perché
qualche giorno prima a mia moglie mi
aveva comunicato che di lì a poco
qualcun altro oltre sarà dall indietro
mi avrebbe chiamato papà i miei suoceri
abitano nel palazzo molto bello in
centro e sotto il palazzo c'è un
parcheggio custodito
noi eravamo in fila dietro alcune auto
in attesa che il custode ci facesse
entrare sarà però cominciava a dare i
primi segni di sclero di solito c'è un
che rappresenta l'avviso di esplosione
che ha un figlio lo sa quando urla non è
affatto piacevole
in particolar modo quando lo fa in
macchina dove rimbomba tutto diventa
veramente difficile mantenere la calma
mia moglie per anticipare tutto questo
ha preso la bambina dal seggiolino e mi
ha detto tre parole che io non
dimenticherò mai
ti aspetto su avete mai visto una
puntata di otto gross quasi tutte le
puntate di dottor house inizio allo
stesso modo c'è una persona che sta
giocando a basket
tutto scorre tranquillamente quando ad
un certo punto parte della colonna
sonora è quella persona boom crolla al
suolo la scena successiva e il dottor
house che analizza la tac e la risonanza
magnetica si confronta con wilson
foreman gli altri medici è insieme via
via escludono possibile diagnosi lo
fanno con dialoghi abbastanza surreali
per cercare di arrivare ad una cura
se c'è una cosa tipo sospetto sia uno
stracazzo un bacillo delle asturie an
non ho gli tremava la gamba hai ragione
allora e autoimmune si aveva anche le
trans am inn e alte
beh allora e lupus lupus c'è sempre il
dottor house nella realtà funziona più o
meno allo stesso modo c'è una sola
differenza
la colonna sonora non c'è almeno io l'ho
sentito
pochi secondi dopo che mia moglie mi ha
detto ti aspetto su ho sentito
distintamente un brufolo esplodere
e vabbé dottor house de france aminei
lupus adesso ci racconti di un brufolo
eh sì perché il brufolo da sentito
esplodere nel cranio dentro un istante
dopo nel mio cuore ha preso a battere
all'impazzata io ho iniziato a
biascicare frasi sconnesse e la mia mano
sinistra ha preso a fare su e giù per i
fatti suoi io ero cosciente e lucido
avevo il pieno controllo non sono quasi
pieno controllo della situazione con la
mano che non tremava
ho preso il telefono e ho chiamato mia
moglie dicendole l'unica cosa che doveva
capire chiama l'ambulanza
credo di aver detto grosso modo branza
però lei ha capito lo stesso è infatti
poco dopo è arrivato mio suocero
vi risparmio i dettagli del nostro
dialogo cioè delle sue domande che io
capivo perfettamente alle quali
rispondevo con dei suoni assolutamente
incomprensibili ma capivo pure quelli
pagato io lo capivo tutto quello che
proprio non potevo capire era che da
quel preciso istante la mia vita era già
tutta ma proprio tutta tutta tutta
completamente cambiata quando arrivammo
in ospedale a me era passato ogni
sintomo passato però è un concetto
curioso passato significa che c'è stato
e quella cosa che c'è stato in ambito
medico lascia tracce è infatti le
analizzarono un po come farebbe il
dottor house
il referto diceva sospetto si tratti di
una lesione glial e di alto grado per
questo motivo ho consigliato una biopsia
escissoria per un successivo esame
istologico che verdi abitato non era
lupus
e che cos'era era un caro alessandro hai
un tumore al cervello per capire che
tipo di tumore e quindi se sei ancora
vivo oppure no dobbiamo asportarne il
più possibile cioè avrete il cranio
prelevare quanto più cervello
danneggiato possibile senza tocca pardon
cercando di non toccare le parti vitali
per esempio quelle che controllano il
movimento e la parola visto che biascica
vie 3 ma vi è probabile che siano
coinvolte se non fai parte di quegli 1
su 250mila che già all'anestesia
generale crepa
se riusciamo a rimuoverli questo oblio
ma senza renderti emiplegico o muto se
poi magari ti risvegli argini facciamo
le analisi e ti diciamo che cacchio a in
quella testa
in alternativa spiegheremo ai tuoi
parenti come si chiamava quella roba che
ti ha ucciso
eh sì perché glioma di alto grado può
voler significare anche quarto grado a
seguito della cui e diagnosi chiamano
direttamente il prete incurabile
inguaribile sei mesi a volte
miracolosamente 12 più spesso 2 non
credo di dovervi spiegare com'è andata
ammetto che i 28 cicli di radioterapia
non sono stati proprio leggerissimi e i5
di chemio ecco io non mi sento di
consigliarvi a nessuno io però non
potevo proprio morire c'era mia moglie
c'era il mio bambino stava arrivando il
mio bambino
c'è una frase di un libro di carlos ruiz
zafon che si intitola il gioco
dell'angelo e la frase non posso morire
dottore non ancora ho delle cose da fare
poi euro tutta la vita per morire io e
mia moglie salamon per completare quella
che era sempre stata la nostra idea di
famiglia
noi e due bambini per cui io proprio no
non potevo morire
ricordo che dopo l'intervento mi
mandarono da un bravissimo oncologo e
che mi disse caro alessandro alla
risonanza posto intervento è pulita non
ci sono tracce però sai se c'è una sola
cellula tumorale che non sono riusciti a
rimuovere e alla risonanza non si vede
ma ne basta una perché tutto riporta che
io venissi e quindi è lui mi disse e
quindi io ti consiglio di fare dei cicli
di chemio così spazziamo via tutti
io ovviamente dissi di sì e lui aggiunse
tieni presente che se vuoi altri figli
devi congelare adesso il tuo seme perché
dopo la chemio o diciamo che sarà un po
problematico
noi avevamo già la nostra bambina stava
arrivando il nostro bambino non ne
volevamo altri qui a posto così e
infatti i quindici giorni dopo il 26
settembre 2013 più o meno alle 6 del
mattino è nato nostro figlio e il 26
settembre 2013
più o meno le 7 del mattino se n'è
andato per sempre
all'epoca io stavo leggendo un libro di
chuck palaniuk un libro che si intitola
soffocare c'era una frase di quel libro
che mi colpì moltissimo e che mi porto
ancora dietro e me la porterò per la
vita la frase è non sai mai quanto sei
forte
finché essere forte e l'unica scelta che
ha ri
io all'età di vent'anni ero
assolutamente certo di avere tutte le
carte in regola per diventare un grande
uomo
uno di quelli che ha in questo mondo
lasciano il segno
giunto alla soglia dei 40 sentivo di
essere diventato un vecchio ragazzo uno
di quelli che da questo mondo restano
segnati c'è voluto un po bel po poi ho
capito ho capito che mio figlio in
mezz'ora mi ha insegnato tutto quello
che in quasi 40 anni non avevo imparato
mi ha insegnato a guardare a guardarmi
dall'esterno
anzi dall'alto e mi ha insegnato che
visti dall'alto
sembriamo una fila di corpi distesi a
prendere il sole ci diamo tanta pena per
sfoggiare la migliore tintarella e non
ci rendiamo conto che perdiamo
tantissimo tempo così come dei baccalà
abbiamo la grande possibilità per
ribaltare tutto mettere a soqquadro la
vita riempirla delle cose più utili
dimissioni e imprese che cambino il
nostro pianeta e noi stessi possiamo
guidare rivolte e rendere realtà i sogni
e invece siamo qui sempre fermi e sempre
a corto di energie un gregge di pecore
dove quasi sempre c'è un esemplare forte
un esemplare che capeggia sugli altri e
gli altri lo seguono ma in realtà
nessuno si sta muovendo di un passo
siamo così immersi nelle nostre vite che
non troviamo nemmeno uno scopo a noi
stessi
vorrei trasmettergli quello che mi ha
insegnato mio figlio quando mi ha detto
papà io vorrei che tu fossi dinamico in
movimento uno che si carica in spalla le
avventure di ogni giorno e arriva a sera
con la soddisfazione di essere stato
vivo e attivo
vorrei che tu facessi fruttare tutto il
tuo tempo senza che una sola goccia di
quel dono prezioso vada sprecata e
vorrei che nel tuo tempo trovassero
tanto spazio mia sorella e la mamma con
lei e che il vostro modo di vivere fosse
voglia di sperimentare e gioire di tutto
anche delle cose da nulla quelle
all'apparenza più stupide
vorrei trasmettervi quello che mi ha
insegnato mio figlio quando gli ho detto
papà guardarvi d'acqua sono spesso più
vi guardo e più penso che vorrei farvi
tornare tutti i bambini e dirvi tieni ti
restituisco il tuo tempo per favore puoi
usarlo in un modo migliore e stavolta ci
sono stati dei momenti nella mia vita in
cui farmi un caffè era impossibile non
riuscivo ad alzarmi dal letto non ce la
facevo fisicamente ora che le energie
necessarie tutto il tempo che mi serve
gioisco ogni volta che faccio una
piccola cosa perché lo spazio per quella
piccolezza ieri sembrava non esserci e
quando sono stato messo con le spalle al
muro
ho pensato che quella stupida piccolezza
come farmi il caffè ogni mattina mi
sarebbe terribilmente mancata se il mio
tempo fosse finito ma non è finito e
quindi è tempo di fare mio figlio mi ha
detto papà staccati da quel branco di
pazzi che vive sotto il cielo smettila
di essere quel padre che suona il
clacson per correre a casa a vedere la
partita diventa quel papà che suona il
clacson per correre a casa dai figli che
l'aspettano
sapete quanti bambini vanno a dormire
con il sorriso spezzato a metà per la
mancanza di un padre sapete quanti lo
vorrebbero e l'hanno perduto no non sono
riusciti a strapparlo a una malattia oi
programmi del destino vuole fatalità
alle separazioni o alle guerre
tutti lo cercano con la stessa ansia e
tutti immaginano un gioco che includa
anche lui un eroe sempre pronto a
riparare la bici ea gonfiare il pallone
mio figlio mi ha detto papà correte
correte ma correre per una giusta causa
non quella che mi fa sorridere da quassù
e mi porta a pensare
questi sono tutti scemi sono queste le
cose che mi ha insegnato mio figlio
mi ha insegnato che è meglio avere un
subbuglio un disordine totale ma un
attaccamento vero per la vita mi ha
insegnato che è meglio non riuscire a
trovare le ciabatte ma non avere alcun
problema a trovare la canzone che ci fa
sentire di buon umore e mi ha insegnato
che è meglio perdere le cose nei
cassetti ma tenersi accanto di persone
che si amano e soprattutto soprattutto
mi ha insegnato che non è difficile se
troviamo il coraggio di staccarci da
tante inutilità che ci hanno inculcato
negli anni non è difficile se guardiamo
la verità e le sue piccole magie
allora sì che saremo vivi e non stracci
di pelle a copertura delle ossa
saremo vivi cioè quando godremo il
piacere di una chiacchierata con un
amico di un bicchiere di buon vino
un album di ricordi o una passeggiata al
tramonto
saremo vivi cioè quando godremo di cose
vere ed essenziali
ora voglio leggervi un pezzo di un libro
che è sentito la shantaram ed è una
storia vera
ho impiegato molto tempo e ho girato
quasi tutto il mondo per imparare quello
che so dell'amore del destino e delle
scelte che si fanno nella vita per
capire le essenziale però mi è bastato
un istante mentre mi torturavano legato
ad un muro fra le urla silenziose che mi
squarciavano la mente riuscì a
comprendere che nonostante i ceppi la
devastazione del mio corpo
ero ancora libero libero di odiare gli
uomini che mi stavano torturando oppure
ri perdonarli non sembra granché
me ne rendo conto
ma quando non hai altro stretto da una
catena che ti morde la carne una libertà
del genere rappresenta un universo
sconfinato di possibilità e la scelta
che fai
odio o perdono può diventare la storia
della tua unica vita
ho iniziato questo talk parlando della
magia delle parole
ed è con una parola magica che voglio
concluderlo la parola è adesso
chiedete scusa a qualcuno in particolare
ai vostri familiari
se avete qualcosa da farvi perdonare
viceversa se siete dall'altra parte
accettate le scuse e perdonate fatelo
adesso non aspettate che accada qualcosa
di tragico per poi rimpiangere i momenti
che avreste voluto passare insieme ma
che non avete trascorso a causa del
vostro ridicolo e inutile orgoglio
fatelo adesso perché la scelta potrebbe
essere ridere davanti a un caffè o
piangere davanti a una barra non
sappiamo quale sarà l'ultima volta che
abbracciano una persona non lo sappiamo
perciò abbracciatevi fatelo adesso
ditemi che vi volete bene
fatelo adesso non domani non dopo
adesso grazie
[Applauso]